bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 7 septembre pillage déportation de
population destruction de biens et loi
martiale au timor oriental en indonésie
le leader indépendantiste bousman
libérés par les autorités de jakarta en
appelle à la communauté internationale
en direct de lisbonne le président la
république du portugal monsieur ranger
champions sera notre habitude le
militant syndicaliste agricole josé bové
de la confédération paysanne retrouvent
la liberté après le paiement de la
caution exigée par la justice il veut
continuer son combat contre la malbouffe
josé bové sera en direct de ceux de plus
sa maison
une arnaque des champignons cueillis
dans les pays d'europe centrale sont
déclarés suspect de contamination au
césium issus du nuage de tchernobyl 13
ans après plusieurs camions de ces
champignons ont été arrêtées en douane à
strasbourg
la bronchiolite c'est-à-dire lé
infection des bronches tout chaque hiver
un très grand nombre d'enfants
prématurés un médicament sera utilisé en
secteur hospitalier en france dès
l'automne c'est une véritable
déportation de population qui est en
cours au timor oriental en indonésie
déportation avec navires et camions
fournis par la marine et l'armée
indonésienne pour évacuer selon la
terminologie officielle les réfugiés en
fait des enfants des femmes des hommes
paniqués fuyant les exactions les
pillages des assassinats des milices
indépendantiste certes la loi martiale
était proclamée mais comme il n'y a de
moins en moins de témoins étrangers
on se demande ce que cela signifiera
dans les jours qui viennent et le leader
indépendantiste tchad anna haag ousmane
libéré par gouvernement indonésien
accuse maintenant directement les
soldats d'être responsables des tueries
commentaires maryse burgot
lorsque canada goose mao kick sa
résidence prison de jakarta ce matin sa
joie est pour le moins discrète le pays
pour lequel il s'est battu le timor
oriental est à feu et à sang
sa libération après sept ans de
détention et donc une victoire bien
amère canada goose mao inlassable
combattant de la cause de l'indépendance
de son pays
17 ans de lutte armée et de
clandestinité dans les maquis du timor
traqué sans relâche par l'armée
indonésienne
il est finalement arrêté en 92 et
condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
il devient le mandela de l'asie les
autorités indonésiennes choisissent donc
de signer sa libération anticipée le
jour même où elle décrète l'état
d'urgence au timor cannabis mao livide
demande à la communauté internationale
d'agir
aidez nous arrêter la violence
arrêtez les meurtres aidez nous à sauver
les vies sur les vies des enfants
les rares images en provenance du
timor-oriental montre ce soir des civils
pro indonésien quittant la région de
leur plein gré pas d'image en revanche
des deux cent à trois cent mille civils
déplacés de force vers la partie ouest
de l'île
un début de nettoyage ethnique en somme
visant à vider le team au reste de sa
population indépendantiste
alors que les premiers camps de réfugiés
sont installés à confondre monseigneur
bello trouvent refuge en australie
évêques du timor est une aubaine de la
paix il exhorte lui aussi la communauté
internationale a réagi
une mission de l'onu est d'ailleurs en
route pour jakarta
kofi annan affirme aujourd'hui qu'une
force pourrait intervenir si l'indonésie
ne ramène pas l'ordre au plus vite sur
l'huile les nations unies semblent avoir
bien du mal à gérer les conséquences
d'un référendum qu'elles ont elles mêmes
organisés et cette sorte de nettoyage
par le vide au père et au timor oriental
par les milices avec la complicité
passive de l'armée illustre tragiquement
lady fuite et identitaire de l'indonésie
pays éclaté en dizaine de territoires où
les moindre velléité d'indépendance sont
très vite l'objet de la répression de
l'armée et d'enjeux électoraux
explications jean-marc il ose en tant
que président a donné zia je suis
responsable de tout là dedans y compris
le timor-oriental devant les caméras
celui qui aurait pourtant préféré une
simple autonomie affirmé lundi
reconnaître la victoire des
indépendantistes aux élections
organisées par les nations unies au
timor oriental
oui mais voilà le président habib sy
veut-il ou peut-il réellement arrêter
les massacres dans l'ex colonie
portugaise annexé illégalement par
l'indonésie voilà un quart de siècle
propulsé à la tête comme de 6 millions
d'indonésiens la suite des violentes et
aulas qui pourra voir le diable de
l'ancien dictateur soit la tête du 2e
paria la faune pays n'a pas renoncé à
être désignés en novembre prochain
président de la république
perdu le timor-oriental tout en faisant
mine comme lui de respecter les nations
julie l'indonésie en faillite a besoin
d'argent
quant au chef des puissantes forces
armées indonésiennes le général louis
ranto qui lui aussi prétend vouloir se
ranger à la volonté des nations unies
peut-il vraiment se mettre à dos les
sanglantes forces spéciales chargées de
la contre insurrection dans les
provinces riches de l'archipel rongé par
l'autonomie aujourd'hui comme hier pour
les militaires comme pour les politiques
c'est l'unité et l'identité nationale
qui sont en jeu au timor oriental
tibor est le miroir des contradictions
indonésienne vous y trouvez
l'affrontement entre chrétiens et
musulmans
vous y trouvez les partisans de l'état
central fort l'anneau masi s'est faite
en unifiant souvent de force des
milliers d'îles et vous trouver des gens
qui bien entendu veulent s'en aller
aujourd'hui comme au printemps 80 18 des
étudiants indonésiens manifesté contre
le pouvoir des militaires
un pouvoir obsédé par le timor le
parlement indonésien doit attendre
jusqu'à novembre pour ratifier
l'indépendance du timor oriental en tête
des pays le portugal ancienne puissance
coloniale au timor jusqu'en 1975 même
une très intense activité diplomatique
se faisant direct de lisbonne avec vous
monsieur sampaio êtes le président de la
république du portugal
avez vous le sentiment monsieur saint
pio qu' il y ait une véritable inertie
internationale devant ce qui se passe au
timor bon je ne peux pas dire qu'il ya
une inertie il y a une activité
diplomatique internationale de grande
portée
le problème c'est les limites de cette
activité parce que on comprend bien que
d'après vos reportages tout le monde a
vu dans tout les chaînes de toutes les
chaînes de télévision qu'il y a je
dirais même massacre des déportations
des des incendies tout ce qui des morts
les kaos créé je dois dire même
scientifiquement préparer pour dire le
moins bon alors le problème c'est de
savoir quelles sont les limites de
l'activité diplomatique internationale
il faut quand même remarquer le suivant
on est un processus de autour de termine
à sion signant nations unies supporté
par les conseils de sécurité
une mission des nations unies qui
d'ailleurs a fait
un travail remarquable un référendum qui
a été organisée inscription des votants
votation résultats massifs participation
78% en faveur d'un chemin pour
l'indépendance et voilà que la société
internationale les nations unies sont
confrontés avec l' incapacité de 1
d'implémentation ce qui a été décidé par
le peuple et à leurs apps est difficile
oui mais alors monsieur le président
faut-il déployer une force
internationale comment doit-elle être
composé est ce que j'ai le sentiment que
monsieur kofi annan et ils conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sont prêts à cette
démarche
bon je dois dire que monsieur kofi anan
avec lequel j'ai parlé plusieurs fois
ces derniers jours certains membres du
conseil de sécurité dont la france que
j'ai le plaisir de dire aujourd'hui je
gd entretien permanent avec monsieur
jacques chirac président de république
française oui on est on est exactement
dans le processus de réflexion qui
conduira à mon avis à cette formation
d'une force d'interposition d'une force
de paix le problème c'est monsieur le
président vous mettez tout ça dans le
futur or il ya urgence est ce que il
n'ya pas là aussi certaine incapacité à
se mobiliser
non tout à fait j'ai je fais des
plaidoiries permanent toutes les heures
je sais exactement c'est une chose pour
hier mais je ne suis pas le conseil de
sécurité malheureusement je ne suis pas
de ceux qui disent que effectivement il
faut trouver un consensus possible je
comprends parfaitement bien que sans ce
consensus n'est pas possible j'ai appuyé
le portugal appuient tous les efforts
qui sont en cours cette mission de
conseil de sécurité pourrait évaluer sur
le terrain sur à jakarta nécessairement
quel est le degré de respect de
l'indonésie à ce qui concerne sa
responsabilité d'assurer la sécurité et
je pense que ces 48 heures sont tout à
fait décisive mais alors comment y a
mais comment contraindre monsieur saint
pio les dirigeants de jakarta est ce que
vous avez confiance en eux est ce que
vous pensez qu'en instaurant notamment
la loi martiale
ils veulent vraiment rétablir l'ordre
bon il ya un processus très compliqué en
indonésie je ne veux pas me
percer sur les contradictions internes
d'un processus de transition à la
démocratie
je dis une chose qui à mon avis est très
importante
l'indonésie est un grand pays l'indien
future important à relâcher
c'est un pays remarquable du point de
vue de la position internationale la
géostratégie il y a une crédibilité
internationale de mener 6 qui est en jeu
vis-à-vis tout ce qui est la vie
internationale les institutions
internationales donc le problème je le
dis toujours le problème le processus de
démocratisation en asie va de pair et un
briquet avec le problème de l'autre des
opérations de timor alors il faut que
les 2 termine bien donc c'est à la
société internationale au conseil de
sécurité pour mort permanent du conseil
de sécurité d'évaluer la situation et
comment est-ce qu'on va éviter le
dérapage total le sacrifice les meurtres
qui sont en cours un timon voilà la
décision qui certainement est nécessaire
dans les quatre cdc serrières mais enfin
pour être plutôt optimiste dans les
prochaines 48 heures ne peut pas
du jour 1 journée une chose qui est
évidente merci monsieur le président
rappelle que vous étiez en direct de
lisbonne un autre conflit ayant pour
origine une volonté d'indépendance
continue et s'intensifie dans le caucase
au daguestan la frontière de la
tchétchénie
les rebelles islamistes menacent
l'intégrité de la russie estime le
président boris eltsine qui juge très
sévèrement les militaires russes
incapable de mater la rébellion de plus
le retour à moscou des corps des
premières victimes du conflit provoque
beaucoup de réactions dans la population
russe reportage à moscou dorothée
lyrique et sergei bikoro venaille boris
porte un toast à la mémoire de son fils
il dit de lui c'était un vrai bougies qu
un vrai homme nicolas y avait 19 ans il
est tombé au daguestan le 13 août
dernier ses parents sa fiancée anne
officiers russes l'ont enterré jeudi
dernier quand on est à les identifier le
corps dit le père c'était l'horreur il
ne restait presque plus rien du corps de
mon enfant
l'obus l'a littéralement fait exploser
le sergent nicolas savy n'intéresse plus
personne ni le gouvernement ni l'armée
il était un simple pion de la chair à
canon et aujourd'hui il n'est qu'un mort
de plus mort et enterré
la famille savine a dû se battre pour
rapatrier le corps de nicolay avec
l'aide de ce seul officier j'ai dû
chercher l'endroit où on aller
l'enterrer j'ai même dû fabriquer le
cercueil
il aurait dû se cacher ne jamais faire
son service répète la mer un enfant
leurs enfants distille n'avait pas sa
place dans cette guerre
et pourtant les jeunes appelés sont
envoyés de force daguestan selon la loi
seuls déconstruit volontaires peuvent
être amenés à se battre dans la zone du
conflit
les autorités russes parlent d'une
centaine de morts dans les rangs de
l'armée fédérale
mais en réalité les combats seraient
beaucoup plus meurtrier surtout depuis
l'arrivée le week-end dernier au
daguestan de 2000 nouveaux combattants
islamistes
aujourd'hui le président boris eltsine
s'est fâché contre les militaires il les
a accusés de négligence est sommé de
frapper vite et fort pour mettre un
terme à cette rébellion
qu'importe les discours politiques lydia
n'y croit plus elle a perdu confiance en
boris eltsine perdu confiance aussi en
la russie mon fils va sans doute
recevoir la médaille du courage mais il
est mort un important séisme en grèce
aujourd'hui à toucher athènes et ses
environs d'une magnitude de 5,9 ce
tremblement de terre aurait provoqué la
mort d'une quinzaine de personnes est
enseveli des dizaines d'autres bilan est
évidemment provisoire commenté ramier se
gardait la nuit tombe sur la grèce les
secouristes comme les habitants
continuent à chercher à mains nues et
fouillent les décombres
car la terre a tremblé quelques heures
plus tôt le séisme a frappé athènes mais
c'est au nord de la capitale qu'il a été
le plus violent
ici à metamorphosis une usine s'est en
partie écroulé 70 employés seraient
encore ce soir prise au piège
au total une centaine d'immeubles se
sont effondrés la secousse d'une
magnitude de 5 9 sur l'échelle de
richter n'a duré qu'une dizaine de
secondes
comme par le passé les constructions n'y
ont pas résisté je me souviens du
tremblement de terre de 1980 après le
séisme tous les immeubles avaient été
reconstruits et regarder ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au plein coeur d'athènes là
aussi le seul à bouger moins violemment
mais les habitants ont cédé à la panique
bilan provisoire de cette catastrophe 15
morts plus d'une centaine de personnes
ensevelies
ce soir la terre tremble encore sous la
capitale des milliers de personnes
s'apprêtent à passer la nuit dehors
le militant syndicaliste agricole de la
confédération paysanne josé bové est
sorti de la prison de
villeneuve-lès-maguelone près de
montpellier après trois semaines de
détention et le paiement de la caution
imposée par la justice à savoir 105000
france et son comité de soutien qui a
réuni la somme
récit d'une sortie de prison vécue comme
une victoire avec le reportage de karine
comme asie et parce qu'elles pensent la
liberté syndicale ne s'achète pas mais
elle peut s'offrir après trois semaines
en prison josé bové a accepté que son
comité de soutien paye sa caution 105 me
prend venus de toutes parts des caves de
roquefort aux fermes américaines
le leader aveyronnais de la
confédération paysanne avaient été mises
en examen après avoir endommagé le
chantier du mcdonald's de millau le 12
août dernier
derrière la très gauloise guerre contre
les hamburgers c'est une lutte contre la
mondialisation que livre cet éleveur de
brebis du larzac
le prix est lourd à payer 5 caution de
100 5000 francs pour libérer cinq
militants mais en premi une renommée
inespéré
josé bové a gagné la justice a perdu
quand on tient de justice je le regrette
je pense que j'avais autre chose à faire
qu'on prête à donner comme les causes
que la réponse de la répression on peut
que remercier la justice de nous avoir
fait cette répression parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a eu l'écho que qu'on a voulu
et qui est qui va s'amplifier retour sur
le plateau du larzac les slogans contre
la mondialisation ont délogés ce pour la
démilitarisation
cet après midi à montredon josé bové n'a
pas eu le temps de décompresser dès son
arrivée il apprend la mise en examen de
cinq nouveaux militants un peu en
retrait alice sa compagne analyse la
près avec la sérénité qu'impose le
paysage je pense pas que ça change grand
chose parce qu'il était déjà donc il
était déjà très actif c'est vrai que
mène un bon il sera plus connus mais
mais c'est à lui aussi d'être comme
indiens d'être vigilant quoi sur le fait
de rester de rester lui même de rester
simple
ce soir encore les médias accapare leurs
nouveaux robins des bois
josé bové devra attendre un certain
temps avant de redevenir un simple
éleveurs josé bové bonsoir si je
comprends bien après sur le portage de
karine comazzi on a le sentiment vous
regrettez pas du tout le saccage du mcdo
je crois que quand on mène une action
syndicale on l'assument jusqu'au bout
d'autant plus quand on l'a fait à visage
découvert
et qu'on a décidé de mener une action
pour dénoncer le surtaxation du
roquefort comme nous l'avons fait et
l'organisation mondiale du commerce mais
c'est pas prendre comme bouc émissaire
mcdo je crois que si on s'est attaqué à
mcdo c'est que mcdo aujourd'hui en
france et dans le monde est le symbole
de ces multinationales qui sont à la
fois destructeur des modes alimentaires
des pays mais en même temps destructeur
de l'agriculture paysanne puisque
l'agriculture qui est utilisée pour
faire la nourriture de ce mac donné que
de l'agriculture industrielle dégrader
sans saveur et qui détruit complètement
le goût des décos des consommateurs et
qui est en même temps destructeur des
paysanneries mais josé bové c'est de
l'agriculture française mélodique c'est
de bonne qualité et ça crée des emplois
aussi alors est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
en train de mener un combat qui est un
peu perdue d avance
je crois que le combat si l'on en a pris
mcdo comme symbole c'est parce que
effectivement c'est le symbole de la
bouffe industrielle
c'est le symbole de cette agriculture
industrielle mais en même temps au
niveau des salariés ont dit que mcdo
créé des emplois mais mcdo aujourd'hui
crée de l'emploi précaire c'est un des
principaux producteurs d'emplois
précaires et ceci est absolument ici
puisque les syndicats de salariés sont
interdits chez mcdo et je voudrais
rajouter aussi c'est que mcdo aux états
unis est connu comme étant un des
principaux financeurs de la secte de la
scientologie
on voit bien le modèle qu'on veut nous
imposer en europe bon je m'appelle ça
c'est votre opinion parce que s'ils
veulent vous faire un procès comment
jugez-vous josé bové l'attitude de la
fnra depuis que vous avez été incarcéré
écoutez je regrette que les guyot était
aussi timide sur ce dossier le combat
que nous avons mené concerne tous les
paysans j'aurais attendu de sa part de
rebondir et de participer à cette
mobilisation
je crois qu'il a un peu raté le train
maintenant il peut nous rejoindre nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à travailler
avec lui est d'ailleurs dans les
discussions qui vont préparer
l'organisation le rôle de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
eh bien j'espère qu'il sera à nos côtés
alors le premier ministre jospin a
déclaré je pense que cet homme qui ne
s'était pas d'heureux dérobé doit
pouvoir se retrouver en liberté et il
ajouté il faut me
il faut mener des causes justes avec des
moyens raisonnables
au fond vous sais pas vraiment ce que
vous avez fait pour moi l'action que
nous avons menée je la revendique et
j'appelle ça de la non violence active
c'est à dire qu'on a fait au grand jour
un acte de démontage au début on a parlé
de plus d'un million de francs de dégâts
actuellement les gens du tribunal de
millau sont en train de parler de
l'ordre de 50 mille francs ce qui est
tout à fait dérisoire pour une action
symbolique qui a mobilisé des gens à
travers la planète entière pour dénoncer
les dérives de l'organisation mondiale
du commerce et le diktat américain
merci josé regret à propos de malbouffe
la dernière alerte et sérieuses un
camion venant de bulgarie et de roumanie
et transportant 17 des girolles et des
pieds de moutons ont été jugées
suffisamment suspect pourrait être
repoussée par la direction des douanes
de strasbourg ces champignons seraient
contaminés au césium
c'est à dire que treize ans après
l'explosion du réacteur de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl en ukraine la
contamination radioactive existe
toujours dans de nombreux pays de
l'europe de l'est vous allez voir sur
cette carte pays de l'europe de l'est
speed l'europe centrale les produits
alimentaires dont ces champignons ne
sont donc pas a priori dangereux pour
une consommation réduite mais le
principe de précaution est désormais la
règle
reportage eric lemasson et alexis
delcourt le passage à la douane de
strasbourg n'était jusqu'à présent
qu'une formalité pour ce brave routier
ukrainien tout surpris aujourd'hui de
voir son chargement de vulgaires
champignons considéré par les douaniers
français comme une matière hautement
suspecte les cèpes des centres elle les
girolles on est repassé au compteur
geiger
c'est une nouvelle réglementation
européenne qui l'imposent
au nom d'un principe de précaution
treize ans après tchernobyl
nous faisons des contrôles aussi sévère
que ce que j'aime de décrire depuis
l'entrée en vigueur du règlement
communautaire
auparavant nous faisions depuis fin
juillet 99 cependant auparavant nous
n'étions pas inactif évidemment ces
produits étaient contrôlés mais contrôlé
suivant la norme requise
auparavant depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
cette nouvelle précaution douanière
surprise en un mois déjà quatre
chargement suspect de à lille ii à
strasbourg ont été réexpédiées à
l'expéditeur bulgare analysé dans ce
laboratoire de la répression des fraudes
les champignons des pays l'est
présentait un taux de césium 137 et 134
2 au 1400 becquerels par kilo soit
quatre fois la norme autorisée
c'est à la fois important parce que l'on
peut pas tolérer qu'il y ait des
produits de fission
au delà d'une certaine
activités classiques mais en même temps
c'est faible relativement au rayon à
l'activité naturelle de tout organisme
vivant dans ce labo on affirme
solennellement que la france n'a pas
attendu la nouvelle norme européenne
pour surveiller les champignons des pays
de l'est
1500 échantillons prélevés chaque année
nous dit on il n'empêche que pendant des
années depuis la catastrophe de
tchernobyl des milliers de tonnes de
champignons plus ou moins comestibles
ont vraisemblablement franchi nos
frontières jusqu'à nos assiettes
encore un effort messieurs les
nationalistes c'est le sens des derniers
propos tenus par lionel jospin en corse
après une visite de à sartène
aujourd'hui chez le maire communiste
dominique bucchini et parmi des
exploitants agricoles mais comme en écho
le groupe clandestin flnc canal
historique à rejeter cette invite du
chef du gouvernement
en revendiquant aujourd'hui six
attentats et deux tentatives d'attentats
commis récemment encore ce reportage est
vite imbert michèle fines et jacques
gregor j'espère il m'est arrivé il y
avait de l'orage dans l'air ce matin je
termine un clin d'oeil face à la
violence des éléments la violence des
armes elle n'a pas fait sourire lionel
jospin
l'arrêt de cette violence comme
préalable à tout changement en corse
telle aura même été son leitmotiv
pendant ces deux jours comme ce matin à
sartène ici règne dominique bucchini un
maire communiste qui s'est dressé contre
les dérives nationalistes à sartène les
principes posés par lionel jospin ont
trouvé un écho aussi bien sûr c'est
qu'elle a répondu aux nationalistes dit
la vérité est dit et ce qu'il faut qui
se passe en corse c'est à dire
à dire arrêter la violence arriver
ce rachat est
auj
le chant polyphonique du groupe granit
ou maggio une certaine corse en version
originale la corse que le gouvernement
affirme vouloir aider le contrat de plan
est allé jusqu'en 2006 c'est une
enveloppe de plus d'un milliard de
francs le led à condition de pouvoir
dire les choses avec franchise comme
dans le monde agricole où les pratiques
doivent être assainis lance le premier
ministre enfin un message sans équivoque
à l'intention de ceux qui en corse même
s'ils sont très minoritaires ont fait de
l'assassin présumé du préfet erignac
yvan colonna toujours en fuite
un héros lorsqu'un homme a été
accompagné son épouse au théâtre qu'il
est venu tout seul lui préfet qui
pouvait être protégés garer sa voiture
qu'il a remonté tranquillement une rue
pour aller la rejoindre
écouter de la musique en faisant
confiance à tous qu'on s'approche de lui
et qu'on lui tire une balle dans la tête
ça fait pas de vous un héros au moment
même où lionel jospin achevé sa visite à
bastia ce soir
le flnc canal historique revendiquait
six attentats dont celui perpétré la
veille même de l'arrivée du premier
ministre en corse la fin de la violence
sur l'île est encore à conquérir
pendant ce temps au sud de terre-neuve
le président jacques chirac était à
saint pierre et miquelon où l'on a
évoqué le statut de cette collectivité
territoriale
on aura noté aux côtés du chef de l'état
la présence de renaud muselier petit
fils de l'amiral muselier qui participe
à la libération de saint pierre et
miquelon
mais renaud muselier qui le député de
marseille est aussi l'un des actuels
candidats déclarés à la présidence du
rpr au deuxième jour de la rentrée
scolaire on prête surtout attention
différents couacs des postes
d'enseignants qui manquent à albi une
fermeture de classe près de roanne un
ancien instituteur âgé de 83 ans à saint
georges de bach oil dans la loire qui
fait une classe maternelle sauvage et
puis à gennevilliers dans les
hauts-de-seine 30 écoles maternelles et
primaires portes fermées afin d'obtenir
plus d'instituteurs reportages et les
amarres goût et alain poirier
au deuxième jour de l'année les enfants
de jeunes filles et font déjà l'école
buissonnière faute d'enseignants
première grève première fausse note de
la rentrée 21 postes d'instituteurs
n'était toujours pas pourvus hier du
coup les trente écoles de la ville sont
restées fermées
et pour occuper les enfants les
enseignants en colère les emmener en
balade éducative devant leur ministère
qui sont commencés ils doivent se dire
devenir quelqu'un ajoute que nous on est
encore en vacances quoi elle est restée
dans la cour à s'embêter de 8h30 le
matin jusqu'à 80 le comigui encore quoi
on aimerait bien voir des preuves ce
qu'on montre à venir pour trouver un
travail plus tard et où on s'était pas
pour une rentrée des classes ait pas de
marin pour les enfants c'était de
rentrer à l'école et que travailleur en
même temps
franchement vous a vraiment déçu la
situation était pourtant prévisible dès
juin
trop peu d'enseignants ont été recrutés
par rapport aux besoins du département
l'administration pense est en fait
envoyé dans les classes d instituteur
remplaçant pour occuper les postes
vacants
on est en train de faire des opérations
cavalerie où on prend des remplaçants
des gens qui sont censés avoir d'autres
tâches pour les mettre dans les casses
temporairement en attendant qu'on
recrute
et pendant ce temps il ya des collègues
qui ont été reçus au concours et qui
attendent eux d'être embauchés et c'est
ça qu'on compte que personne ne comprend
simple incident technique selon
l'inspection d'académie avant la fin de
la semaine les postes devraient être
pourvus en recrutant les nouveaux reçus
au concours de jeunes enseignants sans
expérience et qui ne sont pas encore
passés par l'institut de formation des
maîtres
pour eux aussi l'année scolaire
on est d'être longue et puis pour la
corvée de couverture des livres et des
cahiers connaît quelques soirées chargé
voici un bon moyen de se soulager une
manière de se rendre utile
l'organisation handicap international
qui propose ceci dans de nombreuses
librairies découvre livres le coût est
de 20 francs dont cinq au profit des
enfants handicapés
pas de rennes en ille et vilaine le
forcené qui s'était retranché dans sa
maison après avoir tué quatre voisins et
blessé un cinquième hier ses rangs du
tarot dans la nuit aux hommes du groupe
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale
le meurtrier âgé de 45 ans était
visiblement sous l'emprise de l'alcool a
précisé le capitaine des gendarmes
la bronchiolite est une infection
respiratoire d'origine virale qui touche
chaque année en hiver de très nombreux
enfants dont des nourrissons prématurés
un médicament sera commercialisée à la
mi septembre en europe médicaments de
prévention qui sera administré en
secteur hospitalier en france
ce médicament annonce peut-être dans les
cinq ans à venir la mise au point d'un
vaccin
explication benoît thevenet pour la vie
de ces grands prématurés les infections
respiratoires comme la bronchiolite
représente un danger réel c'est à eux
qui est destiné ce nouveau médicament
appelé palisir human il permet de lutter
contre le virus vrs responsables de la
majorité des bronchiolite
il ne s'agit en aucun cas d'un vaccin
mais d'un traitement préventif qui sera
injectée en cinq fois au moment de
l'épidémie
c'est à dire entre novembre et avril
l'indication actuellement est
essentiellement destinée aux nouveau nés
prématurés nés avant le la 35e semaine
sept mois et qui en moins de six mois au
moment où l'épidémie va débuter c'est à
dire vers la mi-octobre début début
novembre
impressionnante mais efficace pour
dégager de bord la kiné respiratoire
reste donc la seule technique de soins
valable pour les autres enfants ceux
pour lesquels la maladie n'est pas
mortelle
le nouveau médicament à lui un objectif
clair faire diminuer le nombre
d'hospitalisations pour cause de
bronchiolite utilisé l'an dernier sur
cinquante mille nourrissons aux états
unis il a permis de réduire de 55 % le
nombre d'hospitalisations des
nouveau-nés à haut risque cette année en
france le médicament ne sera pas
commercialisé directement en pharmacie
il ne sera administré qu'en milieu
hospitalier
alliée et ce sont les hôpitaux qui en
supporteront la charge environ 30 mille
francs par enfant
cet hiver seules quelques centaines de
nourrissons très fragile devrait donc en
bénéficier
mais d'ici deux ans ce traitement
concernera entre 100000 et 200000 grands
prématurés ou bébé souffrant
d'insuffisance respiratoire sévère
agréable piqûre de rappel de vacances
maintenant avec l'exposition glissexpo
qui s'achève à anglet au pays basque qui
allait consacrer aux marchés des sports
de glisse force est un secteur en pleine
expansion car il y à la glisse des
villes l'église de montagne et la glisse
de mer et dans ce marché de la glisse
les vêtements adéquats connaissent une
augmentation de leurs ventes de 25% par
an sur cette déferlante sportive
industriel voyelles en quête d' eric
perrin et philippe du mail paris la
capitale de la mode mes racines oblige
c'est à anglet au pays basque que la
glisse tient salon un salon à l'image de
son marché pas comme les autres pour les
défilés naomi et claudia ont été
éliminés après l'épreuve de sportive
ce sont des danseurs qui présente la
nouvelle collection et et demi vingt
mille mètres carrés réservés aux
professionnels
800 exposants 30000 visiteurs les
affaires marchent depuis six ans le
marché de la glisse progresse de 25%
chaque année chiffre d'affaires 10
milliards de francs en europe c'est très
démocratique mais maintenant il ya un
quart de 38 ans et trois quarts
non pratiquants réguliers où je veux
dire dans le sens où c'est un peu le
rêve je crois que c'est ça correspond
maintenant le rêve c'est cela acheter un
vêtement de surf wear c'est aussi
surtout devenir membre d'une tribu
chronos et des valeurs plaisir liberté
et même un certain individualisme grâce
au skate et roller la glisse a conquis
une nouvelle clientèle dans les villes
majoritairement jeunes et volatile pour
la conserver les marques leaders font un
peu de publicité mais consacrent près de
la moitié de leur budget au sponsoring
d'événements ou de champion c'est
capital on s'adresse à une clientèle
très jeune très sélective est très
passionné en même temps et c'est très
important pour la légitimité de la
marque
à côté des plus grands big silver
prévoit cette année 900 millions de
francs de chiffre d'affaires en europe
apparaissent des nouvelles marques comme
source l'histoire de six copains de
moins de 25 ans qui ont investi 4030
chacun emprunté aux amis pour une
première collection leurs atouts être
tout petits les sports de glisse sont
devenu une mode
donc tout le monde s'habille comme ça et
les puristes bon jeu pouvons aller
chercher la petite marque qui peut être
dans dix ans sera à nouveau
marc voilà voilà selon une étude récente
la glisse arrive en deuxième position
après le football au niveau de l'intérêt
pour les 15 25 ans la vague n'a sans
doute pas fini de déferler
on a appris aujourd'hui le décès de
l'ancien coureur si fils thierry
claveyrolat cet ancien détenteur du
maillot à pois rouges de meilleur
grimpeur au cours du tour de france 90 a
mis fin à ses jours il était âgé de 40
ans du football demain l'équipe de
france rencontre l'arménie lui faute
impérativement gagner pour espérer se
qualifier pour la phase finale de l'euro
2000 mais en arménie avant même le match
l'arrivée de l'équipe championne du
monde n'a été tout un événement d'autant
qu'au sein des bleus il y as boghossian
et djorkaeff reportage trop andré
germain dans l'avion de l'équipe de
france deux joueurs attendaient depuis
longtemps ce moment là le déplacement en
arménie n'est pas qu'un simple match de
foot pour youri djorkaeff et alain
boghossian
les deux joueurs d'origine arménienne
n'avait jamais foulé le sol de leurs
ancêtres
depuis cet après midi c'est chose faite
dès sa descente d'avion djorkaeff a
droit à un comité d'accueil particulier
tout le monde l'appelle youri tout le
monde veut le toucher l'embrasser
plus qu'un champion du monde il est
l'ambassadeur français du football
arménien on en oublierait presque le
match de demain
on est là pour un match important et
je suis content c'est nouveau j'ai vu ça
c'est beau c'est magnifique
je crois au centre ville d'airé vannes
c'est l'effervescence devant l'hôtel des
bleus il fait chaud plus de 30 degrés
mais les gens attendent la sortie des
français la réplique de la coupe du
monde fait un tabac mais ce n'est rien
comparé à l'hystérie qui s'empare de la
foule quand youri apparaît reçu comme un
chef d'état plus populaires qu une
rock-star djorkaeff est adulé ses
efforts pour la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien ont fait de lui un
personnage central de la diaspora
mais demain sur le terrain il sera du
côté des français pas question d'oublier
l'enjeu du match les bleus doivent
gagner sous peine de ne pas participer
au prochain championnat d'europe
le plus important c'est les trois points
ça faut pas l'oublier
depuis deux jours les entraînements
français se déroule à huis clos
mais hier soir nous avons pu espionner à
la jumelle depuis le dix neuvième étage
de notre hôtel
l'entraînement des bleus et nous avons
remarqué la présence dans l'équipe des
titulaires probables du duo bordelais
las landes wiltord aux côtés de
djorkaeff l'idole locale
voilà la tac qui devra faire plier
l'arménie et ben c'était bien vu florent
car voici la composition de l'équipe
telle qu'elle a été communiquée par
l'entraîneur roger lemerre il ya
quelques instants
le changement est donc en attaque avec
la présence des deux bordelais sylvain
victor et lilian laslandes anelka est
remplaçant et puis du tennis aux
internationaux faccini dos à new york
nicolas escudé a battu le chilien
marcelo rios tête de série s'est donc
qualifié pour les quarts de finale c'est
une belle performance pour le français
nicolas escudé place et 136e mondiale
côté féminin mary pierce est également
en quarts de finale et puis on attendra
l'issue de la rencontre pioline face à
l'allemand tommy haas pour savoir si le
numéro un français rencontrera en quart
de finale le brésilien gustavo kuerten
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je vous rappelle deux informations nous
avons développé les autorités
indonésiennes qui encourage l'évacuation
du timor oriental la loi martiale était
proclamée le leader indépendantiste
bousman libérés par les autorités de
jakarta en appelle à la communauté
internationale tout comme le président
portugais jorge sampaio qui était notre
invité un important séisme en grèce a
touché à peine et ses environs d'une
magnifique de 5.9 ce tremblement de
terre aurait provoqué la mort de 18
personnes au moins et en syrie des
dizaines d'autres le bilan est toujours
provisoire
dans quelques instants la météo avec
nathalie rihouet et puis le destin des
statues ornent la troisième partie à 0
heures 15 le dernier journal de la
rédaction sera présentée par laurence
ostolaza et demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra de michel
edouard leclerc à 13h mon travail car on
espère et rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir merci